i don't believe no it's not sad ever
it's it's way better and it's just so
uncomfortable can i hear that again i
don't believe in sex ed in schools what
do you believe in them i believe that
your parents should be in charge of that
i don't think the government should come
in i would not have i could i could not
i wouldn't
as a girl you know the creepiest
teachers were always the gym teachers i
think that
i'm scared
i've ever had when have you ever had the
gym teacher teach sex ed
well i just think i just think okay if
you're like you're giving predators
access to children you're blowing my
color right now what but it just no it's
not going to be teachers like period
well i know but you can't model but i
like you can't filter that out and i
just think like you're giving predators
and act like men and women predators
access to children at a very young age
and like why like i don't understand
what a stranger is going to teach my
kids better than i can teach them
uncomfortable from you to get it from
your parents though yeah
but a stranger is better nobody likes
what i'm saying
doing it in school on the safe under
like you know on this like as safe as
you guys it's one thing right but i
don't know one kid would that i would
want like i would personally would never
want my mom or my dad or anyone from my
family to come up to me and be like this
is how you put a condo i would never
want to hear that i would never want to
hear them come to me and be like this is
what sex is this is how you do it
because you want to hear that from a
stranger and then two two the other
thing is every girl that i know that's
had an abortion honestly had the most
educate like one of them one one of them
was a nurse had the most education and
the most accessed information and they
were just irresponsible like they were
just irresponsible like yeah can i ask
the question yeah
[Music]
is there any level of certification that
you think should be provided by schools
no none
like outside of biology like but like
bulletin sex education would go hand in
hand so it's kind of hard to pull them
apart
just trying to understand that yeah are
you saying are you i'm trying not
like okay wait did you do that we had we
had no sex out at my high school we had
no pr like no
have you been pregnant before and that
what have you been pregnant before no
okay no no no i'm sorry i'm just awesome
because you didn't yeah
well no i mean i could say no
and that's that's what i'm saying like
like if if the theory is that sex ed
helps get rid of unplanned pregnancies i
have not seen data to indicate that it
helps and if anything it was the
opposite because abortion rates have
gone up and when they and when sex ed
entered schools it wasn't like teen
pregnancies drastically reduced but wait
okay sorry but would you say like
abortion rates have gone up just because
like the laws have changed now and now
like it's become like more like open for
people to get them because like i know
before like
it was it was like against the law for
like and it was very stigmatized yeah
exactly now so that's why people would
just do it like secret and maybe they
just don't keep track of it now
i mean before i if i had to guess i
don't know but if i had to guess i think
it's because people are more reckless
every like
when i
when i talk about on the show just like
wearing condoms like guys are always
like oh no like
and it's just like people don't even
wear condoms when they have sex with
random people i thought i feel like you
don't even i feel like that's a bit uh
unfair and that's this is coming from
like from the women's side of that yeah
i'm more on the one side now because it
shouldn't have to be a case of like oh
i'm not choosing to work on this oh it
should be practice safe sex type thing
so like if a woman says like like
strap up like i you have to respect her
wishes i'll be on you know i mean but
then like what most guys do what i used
to do when i was yeah
um
i
i prefer not to wear a condom right
because it doesn't feel as natural as
they would say right
but like the way of most you have sex
right but you have you you know but you
have the information to know it's better
right yeah but you just prefer it but
that's that's what like i don't think
any amount of information is gonna you
know the information
is because because most men think think
like this right like i don't have to
wear it because now like like you said
now we have the plan b pill the morning
right the
what's it called the birth control the
injection and stuff right implants yeah
so why would i need to use the call like
most men like why would i usually use a
condom if you can just oh pop a pill
like i mean yeah you know but at the end
of the day i think stds is the answer
yeah yeah pretty much yeah but i'm just
saying like i just i genuinely there
there's so much information we have the
internet we have like and i don't i just
think people don't want to practice safe
sex even if they have the information
i do think it should stay in schools
though because i feel like it's good not
to sense information from children i
think
because some homes maybe it's just not
like different cultures different
backgrounds might talk about sex at
different ages and i feel like sometimes
they might miss the mark where the kid
is going to start
who knows you better than your parents
your parents know the kid better than to
have the best interest of the kids
let me finish and they let how they have
the best interests of the kid like they
have more incentive to have the kid turn
out to be a good person that a stranger
is going to have so you're going to why
does the stranger know when the best
time to introduce sex into that kid's
life like educate them and all that
stuff like why do they know better than
the parents it's kind of the policy of
the school right so
in that school so maybe with that in
mind right so a group of strangers like
why do they know better than than the
parent but the information doesn't
change no it's just more censored
no no what was going to say it was like
the reason why i said i i reached you to
some extent right but
when i said that um the sex education in
the uk is atrocious
what was my point was to that right is
because when the actual day everyone
gets a notification or whatever like oh
we're going to have sex education this
day and then i would my travel if it was
a stranger i wouldn't travel it would be
a professional person or or governing
bodies right that sense of person that
knows about education who's trained in
that to talk to you about it rather than
have your maths teacher or your
geography teacher showing you how to put
a
condom on on on our facebook have you
guys seen sex education yes it's a great
it's a great definition like i do like
the concept that having like maybe a sex
educator come into school so make a huge
difference and it's also like you would
respect the information more so if
you're having your geography teacher
your homeroom teacher tell you you
should do it this way this way you're
like
most of the most of the guys like like
all of that
yeah i also want to bring a point that
you like brought up like you know
sometimes like family households they
have like different cultures and like
for instance like my family like we
don't we wouldn't bring we don't talk
about this kind of thing so like i
didn't know anything like the only thing
that would be like oh don't have a
boyfriend until you get to college don't
do this don't do this don't do this and
then obviously being the rebel that i am
what's what's your boy what's up
what's your cultural background sorry
i'm chinese malaysian so my mom's from
malaysia my dad is from china i'm first
generation american
and so you would see like where that
cultural difference is you know yeah
it's different to like western culture
rebel without a clue yeah yeah what a
rebel without a cause
but i mean like that's where you would
like for me like
like i like i mean like i literally like
learned everything through school like i
needed that what did like what did you
need to learn like i i i went to
catholic school we had no sex ed but i
just it's common sense like where can i
i don't know
i don't think it's common sense for a
lot of kids because a lot of kids really
like their culture probably wouldn't
cover that thing and like
yeah when you watch some tv
if you live in the u.s or the uk you're
telling me you're not going to hear what
birth control and condoms are i mean
like 13 i was like still climbing trees
like i was the the most tomboy
education i can't i don't think you can
really say common sense because you're
so young and then like usually when
you're kids like you're just making fun
of all these things right you're like so
awkward yeah like you're doing like you
know
that's just the most awkward thing
there's one thing that's important but
when they actually show you like
pictures and stuff like that and they
try to them as uh
like you kind of learn like oh it's like
this is like a real thing and it's not
really like a joke and it's a serious
thing you know also for like sexual
preferences as well so at school in the
uk you don't really learn anything about
like homosexual relationships so let's
say you're homosexual like you wouldn't
probably learn that from your parents
either like what you should do so having
access to that it's all over the media
though but like like how would you like
your child to search up like oh how to
have sex as a mat with a man or how to
have something no i don't but i don't
want to teach you're teaching them that
either
i mean like why does my 16 15 year old
need to know that
no
education wise right they teach about
like the like the first time right now
the
how was
from what from what you was told from
what you
expected how was like your actual first
time because it wasn't really that all
that great personally for me the first
time that i've had it it was very
uncomfortable as you would take as you
you always expect you know like birds
and whatever
and it's like yeah but it wasn't it was
never like that so it was just like it's
just i had i had a great time
oh yeah you just you lied that you know
i yeah think i get what you mean like
there's a lot of things that you see
like what you see in tv and what you
learn in school both things are really
unrealistic like there's no there's no
middle
in the middle where you get like a
balance of both like okay it's gonna be
like this or it's gonna be like this
it's not realistic yeah cause like the
first like honestly the first time that
i've had it right
it was was uncomfortable because like
i was under the miscomprehension about
like i was watching a lot of movies and
you know like a lot of like the
sex education classes from whatever so
the first time in the movies and all
that stuff you know i was like oh
all of that and it really wasn't it was
like you're looking at i'm like it's
just is it is that something is that
happening did it happen like you know
it's one of those it's one of those
weird things
i think that's where like we're both
school and kind of like media really i
don't know
has no me social media
social media has such a huge influence
actually i have a question so if you
believe in sex ed in school do you think
they should educate women on how like
the more partners you have the lower
chance you have at a happy marriage
i think that's a different topic i think
education should be like biological and
focus on that kind of aspect
and this relationship is probably more
of like a
philosophical topic well it's not like
it's like based on like like multiple
babies
yeah
no no i'm serious because if we're
talking about we're in sex ed we're
educating people on the ramifications of
sex right if you have sex with one
person you have an 80 chance of having a
happy marriage in 20 years if you have
sex with one it drops down to like 40
50. and if it's more than five it's like
20 percent
and and so that's like a ramification of
sex so i'm asking like do you think
that's something you would add in sex i
don't know like sex ed should probably
like stray away from people's opinions
because it should be like strictly
focusing on like like data so that would
be data
no because that's like an opinion i feel
like that's going into the direction of
like this is what someone believes no no
it's not studying that so there's
multiple studies that have been peer
reviewed by different people that had
nothing to do with each other that came
to the same conclusion you wouldn't say
that but let's focus on the random
implications of sex in a relationship
was there some focus on the actual sex
itself and i think sex education should
focus on the sex itself okay like making
that a healthy and safe process i think
that's probably a different topic for a
different part of school i'm not sure
where it would go also i don't think
when you're doing sex like
sex education you shouldn't like i feel
like um you shouldn't try to like make
them like straight towards like doing
this doing like influencing that kind of
way yeah
so you don't think teaching them how to
put on condoms is influencing them one
way but i mean that's not like that's
for like protection you know i feel like
that's just something
what if they do what they're doing
like if they do what like that is
influencing them one way because you're
teaching them how to put on a but you're
not like telling like go have sex you're
just right right like how to protect
themselves from diseases and everything
else so in the same way i wouldn't tell
them like go be at chase it's just
putting the data out there and saying
this is like you can make your decision
basically okay yeah i feel like i feel
like in schools you should really stray
away from like kind of
influencing people because at that age
like people are very like i know myself
like at like 16 17 like whatever my
teacher told me like oh my god this is
so true like yeah listen to it and it's
like at that age you need to be careful
what you like feed children because they
will take it with them yeah like you end
up doing the opposite
yeah like they're at a very
the age is like a very vulnerable age
for like mindset and things like that
where did you go to school
near birmingham in the uk in the uk
um yeah california i'd say too i'd say
to your school in israel but if you have
already been influenced by school and
anything you've learned specific
specifically in history is written and
have been taught you in a biased slant
as and hasn't been the real
history that epic has existed in the
world history is written and expressed
by those who one who win wars yeah lots
of things that you've missed out on and
i don't quali understand so i hear what
you're saying about situation but
everything we learn
and listen and everything we've learned
in school is it has a biased yeah but
like in birmingham for example there was
like a rule that they stopped teaching
sex education about homosexual
relationships and there was like a huge
protest about it so like can you imagine
if you go to a school that don't teach a
certain aspect like the sense of the
education and go into a school that they
do like they don't like they do sense
information like there's a completely
different education that you're going to
have but one way you can look at all the
information make your own choice and
then one way you don't even have access
to the information and i feel like
having access to information is always
better but then the thing is like um one
thing that i've noticed about like sex
education like in let's say for example
if it's like an oil or boys school or
girl school
um
because well i went to a public school
right and we when we had the classes we
would never have the class with the
girls because you know the girls were
learning and stuff like that but what
i've noticed right is the girls well
maybe it's always just my school but
what the girls only learned about the
female side of sex education type thing
like what to do how do you work what's
your body gonna go through this is how
to you know this is what a vagina looks
like you know that type of thing and the
boys only learned about the boys side of
things but they never intermixed which
is like i feel like that's the wrong way
to go about it you the girls need to
know about what the man
is capable of and what he how he works
and the girls and them
what are they i just don't understand
what does a 14 year old need to know
next education okay you only get 12 like
10 in year 10 which is like
six or six years yeah but i would say
like primary school yeah but like at
that age that's when like you know
puberty starts and obviously like that's
when kind of like
they get interested in the other sex
that's why it's so important you know
but also like backing to you like i
would say like from my school when i
learned about it we did do like about
men and women and not just
she's from california yeah